come see me on the road burbank
california flappers comedy club july
15th
salt lake city utah wise guys july 16th
through 17th
tempe arizona improv august 6th through
august 8th
new york city caroline's on broadway
august 12th through 14th
bakersfield california the tremler
brewing company
august 21st hartford connecticut funny
bone
august 27th through 29th
this totally fits my theory about how
the most successful people
i think are people who were rich when
they were young
it all got taken away and then they're
like i need it back
and then they like together
like your your whole identity is that
you're a rich person when you're a kid
like you
you learn that you're rich like so when
you're a kid you know when you like
most of your bad habits you learned when
you were like under three people right
so you learned i'm a rich person i can
just have these things and stuff
and then so you feel like you deserve it
right and you work
for it yeah you you and you talk to the
people a certain way you just have like
a self-esteem that's different
yeah i think it's it's more just like
you're so determined to work for it that
nothing will
nothing will deter you because that's
shakira's story too shakira grew up
wealthy
and then all of her money was like and
he's laughing at the shakira reference
it's just
they're they're height twins they're
literally
always pop culture like you're like
your school is uh tell me more about my
shirt anna nicole smith
okay so tell me more about shakira so
she grew up wealthy she lost it and she
got it and then now she is so
[ __ ] rich like richer than all the
other pups are she wrote that song
like hey uh like what's that song that's
like really popular at all the soccer
games
oh yeah yeah i know i don't i'm not
because you know she's married to
gerard pique well they're not married
well but they have children here
this is the best part of it too you're
correct yeah
it's just that yeah it's like you went
to college for pop culture i know
oh didn't she go to ucla incognito
i don't know actually yeah she went
there and she learned english
and she was like a straight a student
and um but she not even a semester she
like she went there
legitimately esther's she's been um
uh what's her name what were we talking
about shakira she'd been shakira the
whole time
she was like pulls her
i think that's the best that's the best
like recipe for success like if you want
your kid to be successful
just like max out all your credit cards
the first like eight years of their life
and then take it all away and then push
them into the world and they'll make
shakira money what's the age and that
you take it all away
because what was it taken from you it
got taken for me at the age of
eight okay that works so from age
one to eight from birth to eight i was
uh yeah i lived a very charmed very rich
girl life
i also though feel like if your dad had
been
was your dad he had always had money so
he had that right
oh my dad always had money okay so but
if your dad had been poor when he was
little
and had said things to you like oh no we
might run out of this money
i think that it could have not worked do
you know why because it's more than
message not the amount of money like
because i think about it because my dad
like we were fine but we but like he
treated it like we were
going to run out of money at any minute
i wonder why did he do that
he didn't have that much money he grew
up poor and you guys had all your self
made right
what your dad yeah so my dad's just
really smart so my dad
grew up and he he like he took me to his
house and um
he grew up in long island and you know
it was like they
they had my my dad and my aunt shared a
room and stuff but
my grandfather left them and went back
to
like france he was in the militaries in
the army and just married this french
woman and just left them so
my grandmother had to work at a factory
and so she was working all the time and
they weren't like they didn't like
ever get evicted from their house or
anything but his mom was like busting
her ass
did he miss his dad his dad was like
really mean to him but my
a lot of my dad has his traumas with his
dad and they
had reconnected when my dad was
like 18 i think he was just like a
really like angry
hair trigger pressure person which my
dad was too but worked on
and then um what did you think of him
he was weird i mean it was nice to have
like a new grandfather that was fun but
i remember having a pillow fight with
him
and him being very mad at me like he was
gonna like really like very pissed at a
child
in this pillow fight like really mad
that sounds like me
well anyone that would even swing a
pillow at you deserves it they should
know better
well we did all take sort of a nap
together the other day
in my bedroom uh-huh and i thought about
it i was like what would happen
if we legitimately had a pillow fight
and
across the room she's too little i'd be
upset
[Laughter]
i feel like i could take a pill and just
knock you further than
i expected like oh [ __ ] i have a friend
who once gave me a wet willy and we
didn't talk for like three years after
that's right i i remember that oh what
willy though is like
absolutely violating it
and what about a what do you call it
americans call it a noogie
like this yeah what's so bad about that
i'm so glad you said that because it's
all i want to do to you
what is it it's so painful can i show
you without doing it hard
i won't do it hard i swear to god it
never doesn't hurt
it's like if i did this really hard that
literally feels good
i knew she was gonna say that no no no
you know when someone is see how like if
i don't know like in a headlock doing it
yeah it could be i could say i'd be like
oh that's so
which is a letter in my dream did you
guys see that that was a dream sequence
of mine well maybe you have padded
knuckles because mine are just super
like
i just didn't really know i just didn't
hurt her no it started to be like oh
that's annoying
did you give people noogies ever never i
got i'm not giving you i feel like i
have i've
had luck to you in the past about
wedgies did you give wedgies no i didn't
assault people did you get wedgies i've
never heard she's
you have to be taller than them together
i didn't assault other children did you
no wait maybe we should announce happy
pride
oh yeah oh yeah happy pride we weren't
just stealing these uh
right look we weren't just rainbow
washing we're not that company right
we actually care about our lgbtq
community
yes we do and in honor of pride since i
had no rainbow clothes
i wore my anna nicole smith's shirt she
since i feel like she's kind of a queer
icon she's an icon yeah like
for the gay community this is the least
anna nicole shirt to the
it's so like understated she's so muted
this was from like this limited edition
guest collab like five years
ago and look did i want the shirt to not
be a men's size
yeah but i didn't know when i ordered it
why why
well if you buy it then you can grow
into it but it was like it was like 95
what about anna nicole speaks to you her
beauty
um just that she loved marilyn monroe
too and wanted to be like marilyn monroe
and she was so free and so entertaining
like i love that she
would just make fun of herself
um and just mostly how absolutely
beautiful she was wait do you want to be
like marilyn monroe is that why you're
always in the cake
[Laughter]
you're supposed to jump out of it not
dive into it i
i don't know like i think of being like
marilyn monroe is like
out of the cards for me if that's the
way you say that wait who was our
brunette
in a men's out in a men's shirt maybe
did you wish you were blonde
i never really wished i was blonde but i
looked up to and worshipped the great
blondes madonna britney spears
marilyn monroe and like the blonde yes
the blondes are like
that's who we had and that's what about
monica bellucci
who is that she's just an italian a
goddess
of a woman very curvy she kind of broke
that whole
idea of stick thin we should be talking
about
our brunette i don't know this woman
monica bellucci
oh i recognize her but she's super
curvy bodacious my two favorite looks
are one like the buxom blonde
and then two i love a woman with super
dark dark black hair
and then if she has like light eyes i
feel like that's so beautiful
but i love the card king kim kardashian
is like our brunette icon i feel like
right you're not making faces i'm not
i don't i just know she's not my icon
now um but
she's a lot of people i just like skims
i don't like her that much
but she's like a gorgeous she's clearly
gorgeous no the undeniably
to me though it's like the work and
stuff is weird because it is such a
transformation and it's kind of like if
i'm looking at what i know
of like the beginning of kim kardashian
i'm not looking up to that
but marilyn monroe had tons of face work
too but i didn't
like she wasn't like i didn't watch it
happen you know
she was already like long dead but yeah
there's something about
she was long dead long dead johns
yeah i always looked up i guess it's
like a more narcissistic thing right
like you probably like
look up to people that look more like
you if you're looking at do you have
light eyes
yeah really you do you do have pretty
we have hazel eyes blue no they look
blue
they change they're different yeah i
wrote gray on my driver's license to be
special to be goth to be a liar
because it is a happy pride i wanna
i wanna hear about everyone's little
lezzy stories
and stories of sexual fluidity which we
love and accept about ourselves
yes i personally don't feel a label is
correct for me in my
sexual fluidity or most things like what
is she
what is this
yeah have you guys what's your ex what's
your sexual fluidity and experimentation
history
on a scale of one to ten one being very
hetero
ten being oh let's go with the with
one to five one being very hetero and
five being
fully fully into [ __ ] where would you
i just cannot imagine just being like
let me get that [ __ ]
i just like cannot imagine being like
[ __ ] tear those panties off i'm gonna
but can you imagine someone
a woman saying that to you no oh
but you've had happy pride regardless to
you
i'm like a man but you've had threesomes
yeah but i'm not i never do anything
with the girl it's like always like i
got it
and a lot of times and in college it was
like two guys it was like because of my
boyfriend what
yeah my boyfriend was so gay and he's
married i like can't believe it
i looked at uh he's such a nice people
but i couldn't believe it happy pride
i'm like enjoy your family i'm happy for
you but like bro
wait you had threesome with two guys my
yes
i was dating this guy in college we're
very drunk all the time
and um we would hook up but he always
like wanted to like bring a guy in
and so he'd be at parties and he would
kind of like it was almost like we were
grooming i didn't
i didn't even know what was going on
because i was just like whatever i'm
drunk like let's just hook up but so
then he'd be like
well let's make it like more fun and
then i remember my guy friend coming in
and then he stopped like halfway through
and he just was on the computer
and i was like talk to him later and he
was like he just kept looking me in the
eye
and i was like i know i'm telling you
he's gay gay men would like reach out to
he used to wear a suit all the time
and we just lived in new mexico like
nobody was wearing a suit i don't think
there were jobs that you needed a suit
for it
like he just brought his suit with him
and he would like walk around in his
suit and gay men would reach for him and
i would slap their hands away
i go not when he's mine until he's out
and he's married with children and he
seemed very happy he's got beautiful
families i'm like maybe
maybe i was wrong what happened i was
someone's beard it would be like
um making out and then
maybe some like
he'd go down on me i'd be i'd be blowing
him and then
the other guy was just that like i don't
know just was i don't know he was just
there
like standing right now he was there
like it sounds like it's like making out
with me or whatever i don't know i don't
really remember it
you would just sit in a dark corner over
it
and you would come harder than everyone
no but it wasn't like it was never like
that crazy it wasn't like two
dicks pounding into me or anything it
was really just like i honestly think he
just wanted like a man
to like look at and then my guy was
trying to bang me so he was like
here's my opportunity oh yeah
uh and you you said you were someone's
beard i
well i think i was something isn't it
weird when the beer is a person
[Laughter]
please put a mustache animate a mustache
on top of me
but you don't need to because i have one
i think i was someone's beard
and it was the most abusive relationship
of my life wow it was like grow a dick
yeah the way it was it was bad we'll not
get into it because happy pray
he liked your shoulders i bet oh my god
he like nutted on my shoulders every
time
where do you think you are on the scale
of one day i am very right smack in the
middle
yeah because while i may never feel like
i never
i'm not inclined to eat [ __ ] i will
very much
get you know my [ __ ] eight
really oh yes i will take and i've i've
made out with maybe just as many girls
as i have boys
i just don't care when it comes to sex
it's more like
uh yeah i just i myself
cannot you know partake in the pie but
my pie can be partaken on you know what
i mean
put a bib on me maybe i am gay
no i really feel like i always say i'm
um i do a joke where sam
i was party by in college where i would
like make out with girls at parties and
then
when guys would pay attention i'd be
like bye [ __ ] i'm gonna go get some
dick
because i was very like i was always
down to like make out and stuff like
that but i think i was like that with
everyone i was just
i was like a drunk maker i had to say
that would be my nightmare is if i was
at a party
and i made out with you and i thought
something was going on
and then you were like bye the girls
were never thinking anything was going
they were
doing the exact same thing was doing i
would be we were wearing like
matching knee-highs going like pigtails
like trying to make guys like
go crazy don't worry they know what's
going on but i did have like a weird
almost relationship with a woman that i
kind of talked about on one of these
episodes
i just didn't feel gay like i just
didn't and she was like but emotionally
were you like um you know was it tugging
at your heart
it she well the things that she said to
me that were like
kind of like worked i guess yeah cause i
don't to like
can like say like she was a pret or
anything but she really was like
planting like she was not taking me
being like i'm not
into this as a answer and she was we
just became like really close friends
and she just would say things like well
don't you think the reason
that you've never thought you were gay
is because you were gay and i'm like
what and then i was like
well maybe i was like she just says i'm
so weird that i was like
maybe that's it but it just had never
even occurred i never had like looked at
a woman
sexually like that like i definitely
like admire women's bodies i think
they're beautiful i can see who's hot
but i just never have been like oh you
smell like i want to like tear
it like it's just never been like that
for me we would like make out a lot like
but it was and i remember the guy i was
seeing would get mad at me like you're
leading her on i'm like i'm not
i'm literally all i do is say no i swear
to god i'm not
it's like she's just my friend and she's
always there and it would be like fun to
you know make out with her and
i don't like you talking about esther
this way what the guy
she was always very upset where do you
where do you land on this
i feel like i'm in the middle like i
don't
quite feel ready for like a label
like i don't know i also just don't feel
the need to like come out as anything
and like make some big announcement but
i definitely am like fluid and i'm also
like
going to marry a man so that's like
yeah do we need to come out with what we
are after we like find our part like it
does
no i don't think so i mean i'm like
power to the people who all who are
coming out is what they are like i think
that's cool yeah everyone should be
whatever they are but of course
i also think i'm a little more
comfortable with this conversation now
that i am engaged to
up to my partner because
i feel like my parents would be judging
me
you know like if i was single or
something and said i was into both
genders like i feel like
i i see how that's hard for people to
like handle
i don't know well it's like change well
they did because my parents did make fun
of me when i was little
what did they say i mean my parents like
caught me looking at pictures of naked
women and then they like would call me
leslie and stuff like my whole family
how where were these pictures how are
you looking at them on the internet
on the internet how old were you
elementary school maybe what internet
was there
aol like you could download pictures oh
my god you didn't have that
didn't have that set up that's when the
broke part of my life came in so we
didn't even have
dial up but i did um steal like old
playboys and
in my bedroom i don't know if that's a
bad thing but like we always put i
always put up like naked pictures of
of women i would like that too and i had
a tupac poster and i don't even think i
knew who he was oh we all had a tupac
poster right we're like it's two-pack
but no you guys i bought tupac's
bodyguards book
like you have to imagine that i went to
blair high school like there wasn't
a single white person there except for
cross-eyed pookie
who threw me in a bush but it was
it was yeah it was mostly in black
so my my influences when i first landed
in america
we're purely just like rap hip hop all
of that so he had to
to pack as danny would say was my god
all eyes on me
you know i had a reefer madness poster
what is it what did
reefer madness this like old documentary
about how weed is bad for you
that was a documentary or well it was
like a in
an instructional like it was for schools
what did they say
they were like it'll make you go kooky
it was like really funny it was like
like it's like people you know it's like
when you hear people are going to like
jump out a window thinking they could
fly they really like made it sound like
it was acid or something
oh really yeah but i had a reefer
madness poster
i had a lot of britney i don't think i
had i had sublime
i because my mom was so like rejecting a
femininity
i it is weird that i wasn't i mean
that's how much i was like i think i'm
not
gay but you never know like i really
can't say like if i met someone that
that didn't what do you mean your mom
was
rejecting a feminist she [ __ ] hated
anything girly she would be like ugh
i hate the color pink if i was playing
with dolls i don't get it
but it's all because she was she was
adopted
into a house hold up it was just her and
her brother
and she just really like her and this is
just my guess
obviously i don't know but i do think
that she was like trying to get
attention by like being
one of the boys and so she would always
say she would like go to the park and
like put her hair in a cap and try to go
play baseball which i'm like i think
that was
is that some form of a pygmy girl yeah a
little bit
right yeah do you think your mom is
non-binary
i know no
the thing is she probably was girly i
think she just was trying to get
attention and her mom was very like
pushing her to be feminine
that's how my mom is yeah my mom always
like
tried to dress me up in dresses and i
hated them and
one christmas i got a a baby doll
and i said i won't drive home with it it
has to be in the trunk like i hated it
so much it made me sick
and they put you instead they're like
the dog gets the front seat
and like she was always just trying to
make me look like cute and girly and i
absolutely hated it actually there's a
story
that this is kind of related but kind of
kind of not but
basically when i was two years old my
mom took me to the shoe store i was
trying to get me to try on like these
like girly shoes
and apparently i screamed i don't want
to try on these
[ __ ] shoes wow and my mom just goes
okay we're leaving and we just like left
the store really fast and i'm like how
did i know that she's like
you must have heard your dad on the
phone say that like she said she just
says it as like it's
was the most embarrassing moment of her
life i'd be so proud of my kids
i don't know cussed out loud at jcpenney
say that again sadie can here's a mic my
brother went in my mom was getting us
like snacks after school at a
convenience store and my brother went in
and she was in line and she said mom
this means [ __ ] you
and she was like get the car
esther coco what interferes with your
happiness
so many things like anxiety
where do we get help from better help
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can connect
in a safe and private
online environment it's so convenient
and you can start communicating with a
therapist under 48 hours
dude if you listen to the show it's
actually a legal fact that you need
better help like you need do you need
help there's something wrong with me
there's something wrong with her there's
something wrong with her over there
there's something wrong with you
okay you need better help and it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional counseling
done securely online and you can send a
message to your counselor anytime
which is so helpful because i feel like
if i'm stressing i can just
just get it all out and a message to the
counselor and then it's like off my
chest and we can deal with it later
right and that's my favorite feature as
well as a journal feature where
um i don't have like as soon as i'm in
my therapy session
she knows what we're going to cover
based on my journal entry
that week how about the fact that you
don't have to sit in a waiting room
the service is available for clients
worldwide they have licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in depression stress anxiety
anger lgbtq matters self-esteem the list
goes on anything you share is
confidential it's convenient
professional affordable and you can
check out the testimonials posted daily
on their site
and we want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you'll get
10 percent off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
bloodbath join over one million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's better help
help.com bloodbath
i cannot believe this day has come i
have worshipped this brand
for maybe a year now it's it's got it
all it's funny
and they have the sparkling option for
our little miss thing over here
so liquid death is a new water brand out
there that
looks like a tall boy can of beer and
it's actually
literally just spring water or sparkling
water
but you carry it around people are like
are you drinking beer at 9 a.m and i'm
like no i'm just hydrated
do you know why it's called liquid death
ester why well because it will
brutally murder your thirst and their
infinitely recycled
recyclable tall boy cans are helping to
bring death to plastic bottles i know
which is a very important thing
for you well okay the most important
thing
is if you have not tried flat mountain
water out of a can
you're missing out there's something
about drinking regular water out of a
can that makes me feel
like a king like i feel like i
am so royal i'm royalty they also donate
of the profits from every can sold to
help kill plastic pollution
okay so i am extremely against plastic
water bottles because i like to leave my
water in my car and when the plastic
gets hot it's so nasty
but when you have the can you can leave
it in the heat you can leave it in the
cold maybe not the cold actually i don't
know what aluminum does in the cold but
liquid death you guys it's available
esther i feel like this is your dream
come true
it is you get to stay sober but appear
drunk i
look like i'm cool and like i'm a tough
girl
but it's water this is the ultimate cool
girl drink
it's the ultimate i'm funny but also
healthy drink so
you guys go find liquid death you will
love it liquiddeth.com
have you guys ever gone to any like big
pride celebrations like the big west
hollywood parade or anything like that i
so i used to live in long beach
so long beach our sidewalks are painted
rainbow i used to live right next to hot
java which was a very
very cute gay hub so yes i definitely
um enjoyed pride every year and it was
it's so
fun like it's just even all like my my
mail even like my
my straight male friends would always go
out we'd go out and like cut off shorts
the tightest stuff
it'd be so cute i haven't been to the
pride parade but george can you
put on the screen the silver like
leather fest
oh yes oh i went to that and that was
quite exciting
esther i don't know if you'd be able to
do it i've done the west hollywood pride
before it's really
like it's beautiful like it's so fun and
it's so much
it's fun you know what we should have on
the show is margaret cho
yeah because like how her life was
shaped
was is so interesting because i think
both of her parents
owned like a video store that sold like
adult
like sex videos and stuff like that
didn't they is
and guys we're getting zipped up and
this was the craziest thing i've ever
seen so this was before
it's off sunset that's what it's called
this was like 2005 or something
so i came out here and my friend was i
was staying with my friend who's gay and
he was like oh i'm gonna go to this fest
but he didn't know it was this crazy
either
but guys were getting zipped up and they
had a body bag and guys would get zipped
up all but their balls
they would have like their little
chicken yeah the little chicken heart
hanging out
and then they would get whipped their
balls would get wet
and there was a line it was like crazy
where's your whistle or bell esther
well no i don't wanna i don't i don't
want a king chain but that sounds
really interesting no no to not know
that was literally more power to you if
you want to do that that's incredible
but i just had no clue like my friend
had no clue like oh my god
um esther so you um i watch this
documentary i forget what it's called
but it's about an
old jewish couple and i think they were
from silver lake or i forget where
they're somewhere in los angeles
but they were this old couple that were
the only video store
in los angeles that sold gay porn and
gay magazine circus
uh oaks oh yeah is that what it's called
i don't know i think that's the place
i think it shows but they are the cutest
couple
and what they did for the whole gay
scene in los
angeles is is the best thing i've ever
heard like i cried in that documentary
really have you gone to um gay
dancing at gay clubs esther yeah like i
mean gay clubs obviously play the music
that i
like i definitely have like the music
taste of
a of a gay person it's pretty obvious
well i was listening to some sarah
mclachlan on the way over so i would say
i'm on the other
why why were you listening i just felt
like it what's your favorite sarah
mclaughlin song
well what came on was um angel which is
the dog yeah
the missing eye dog song yeah and the
reason i had it on my
the reason i had it on my phone is
because yeah isn't that weird that you
wrote this song and now it's like
missing legged dogs i had it for making
i made a video
so i had downloaded it to like put that
in the background i can't remember what
it was of but obviously something to do
with
will you make a video to ada i love that
song
such a good oh it's beautiful i'll make
a dance for you
guys please oh and the other one i
really like is
the one that came out a little i was
already in college but like the lyrics
go like
you know and i tried i've fallen i've
sunk so low
oh yes that was so messed up that's my
favorite
that's my favorite one please if you if
you dance to that
esther i will i will cry okay
i would love to make you cry happy
beautiful to you it would be just so
magical if you did and so emotional and
isn't that a great song
it's such a good song i also do you guys
know who sean calvin is
yes okay so i was listening to the song
i just remembered the song out of
nowhere
the song climb on it's the cheesiest
lyrics but i was listening to it on the
way driving over here and i haven't
listened to it since i was like in
college
and i literally got clumped i was like
oh my goodness it's my favorite that's
my favorite word for clumps
i was like is it raining out or am i
tearing up listening to this song about
saving a place in heaven for me it was
really like
some of the lyrics i was like but it
really was like it's just like it's
it's a song about how like you spend
your time like trying to be
strong on your own and then now you can
climb i just i can't even talk about
that what are
you what if i'm on my period obviously
what are some very impressionable music
videos
you watched as um you know either
pre-teen or teenager
like on empty hit me baby one more yeah
baby one more time but i'm sorry
beginning
the cheesy answer even every britney one
um
what was the one oops i did it again is
when she was yeah
right but um the most
amazing thing that i have ever seen that
was the most
life-altering thing was the vmas when
britney spears
ripped that suit off and she had the
sequin thing
and her body was absolutely [ __ ]
ripped in a way that i've never seen a
body be ripped
i i i'm getting chills it was and i'm
not like really
a britney stan i i mean i like i can't
deny that her songs have been very
popular in my head but i don't like
i don't really like follow anyone like
that but it's like it really was like
that
i was like your body can look like that
like you can work out that hard and get
that ripped
and it wasn't even it was in a way that
was athletic
it was so yeah it wasn't like skinny
like she had
the best like her body was i feel like
what part of her like i don't know just
it was such a big deal she had that
stomach where like there was still a
little bit of a champion
yeah and she was so freaking athletic
she was such a true dancer
i don't know if you guys ever saw um
kevin brittany and brittany and kevin
it's chaotic they're like short-lived
reality show
but she had a treadmill in her hotel
room like she would just like
sprint on her treadmill right next to
her bed when she was in a hotel
she was so freaking athletic and i think
she still is really athletic
um but i just i just love it i love an
athlete a little bit no everybody's
still like a female
smoking [ __ ] i was talking to someone
about this remember when everyone was
like oh my god she looks terrible when
she did that performance when she was
like wearing
black something it was like i don't know
oh give me more and everyone was like oh
my god what happened to brittany and she
like if you look back at that now
she looks like absolutely incredible
yeah she was just out of it though
she was like that was yeah that was the
beginning of the
my my very impressionable video for me
was
um aerosmith crazy yeah delicious yeah
silverstone and would love tyler right
like imagine a little filipino girl
thinking that oh when i get to america
that's what i'll be doing i'm jumping
here's my belly button and i'm gonna
somehow it's gonna be strong enough that
i can do a bungee jump
tie it to her belly button and jump off
the bridge no that's the second video
when she jumped off a bridge it's a
different song but she did get her
thing pierced oh i was like i was just
like and then tear out
at the end of the video they they into
it with a guy with a tractor
and then they they do a little crop what
do you call those crap
yeah when they yeah yeah doing like uh
donuts and stuff
i'm looking up some of the most iconic
music videos from the 90s
there was one that really [ __ ] me up
good but i think no one knows it's a bon
jovi one
called always and you know who's in it
and i looked it what they blew my mind
when i was younger because it was the
first thing i saw about like
some partner cheating or philandering on
another but the two girls that were in
it was
um the girl who played felicity oh yeah
carrie
carrie russell and um carla what's her
name gorgeous
gugino what about sorry what about this
the music video or this even just the
song
praise you by fat boy slim what was that
music
like that just came up was that when he
was in the in the
was that what oh it was what's his name
was lip syncing was that when it was i
actually don't remember the video at all
i remember the video this song is just
crazy well in why don't we just go ahead
and shout out prodigy
fat of the land remember that
album no one mm-hmm no takers no taste
it does
peters do you remember that pete i love
that growing up blur
anyone remember blur i remember
backstreet boys i want it that way
music video yeah oh well like best music
videos of all time michael jackson
thriller
right oh is that are we not allowed to
say that no why
but she's saying why that's so funny i
mean i watched a documentary but it is a
great
disney cream you said you're not talking
about it look listen esther
there was more than just a michael
jackson in that video right there were
people dancing their [ __ ] hearts out
there was a director who nailed that job
why should we take that away from them
yeah the people that did a great job
around him
and that's the part anyway the dancing
that but that didn't that music video
when you were little i was like scared
of it when it came on i couldn't watch
it by myself
wait speaking of like pretty epic
cancelled people's work
i just saw coming out of the closet the
r kelly thing
uh the rock opera and i'm like i don't
can't sing but i've got to make a rock
opera that's the funniest thing i've
ever seen in my life
it's really i cannot watch it absolutely
the funniest thing i've ever seen
wait which one is it is the one outing r
kelly with oh no no no no
no no she's talking about like the music
video he made a rock
opera that's like three hours long it's
like in little pieces
and it's it's like it starts out where
he's like hooking up with this married
woman that her husband comes home
and he's just singing the lyrics like
it's so funny r kelly's hiding in the
closet with a gun
which is so funny and then the guy comes
in
sees him then they're like fighting and
for some reason r kelly stays and he's
like
i gotta get out of here it's not my
business like stuff like that but then
he stays
then the guy ends up being like well i
have to tell you something too
and then he calls his lover and then
it's a guy and then he's gay and then
the whole thing is just like
and that's as far as i got but it's so
good wait that sounds
similar to eisley brothers contagious
you're contagious but it's the same
thing
and i think i oddly remember r kelly
maybe
being or not being there but i wanted to
ask you guys um
a pretty risque question and that is
have you ever accidentally or even
willingly hooked up with a married man
no never never i'm also i feel like
in general this is just a general rule
of thumb like i'm not really what a
married man
is like looking to escape from his
reality with
like i i'm not that like tight not even
a man with
a girlfriend no she's a little i i hope
you don't mind me saying you're a little
high maintenance i i think they're
looking for someone that's a little more
side piecey then
yeah i don't have side demands i don't
have side piece
like energy like i feel like i'm
calculating everything in your life like
it's just not i'm not drawn to that i
i almost wonder if it's because i'm my
dad's only child and so like i'm so used
to being like
the center of a man's attention yeah so
that like if i was even felt like
pushed to the side a little bit i would
be completely turned off
yeah i would i'm i'm the same way as
soon as i do
a head to toe and the first thing i hear
or say or i see the ring say for
instance
my brain shuts down my [ __ ] shuts down
there's nothing
i want to do with that
so what happened was um a lot of things
went wrong in the span of three seconds
um this whole production shut down the
lights went down
george was in a panic and then while he
was trying to get [ __ ] together esther
had to go catch a flight so we lost the
little one
we lost one all thanks to you and way to
go george
and that's why i'm not on camera give me
my [ __ ] wait is there like can i have
the
good fruit then do i get the organic
fruit today
are you gonna double fist i'm gonna dick
it
[Laughter]
here's your banana break boys
there was something hold on there's
something in pop culture that
just happened i feel like i don't pay
attention to pop culture and then i come
here and you guys
you guys are my tmz you surprisingly
know a lot of really
fine details though i've had monumental
moments that i can't forget
i can't i can't stop talking about that
britney thing which britney thing when
she tore the thing off
oh i talked about five minutes ago how
did you forget there's so many britney
moments on this show
it's hard to keep up with you guys i
didn't know um
you guys were such a britney stance i
really i like her you know what
now compared to i'm like not a stan i
don't know why i'm not a stan i don't
have like i stand reality tv show
characters that's it you are a reality
um you are um
mtv challenge stan i like seeing people
like being their rawest most
triggered and then also having to like
stand on like a log for 27 hours while
water's pouring on them
like that to me is heaven what's your
favorite top three favorite reality
shows of all time
survivors number one honestly please
keep watching it if it gets canceled i
have no reason to live um did i tell the
story but when i met jeff probst i was
panicked it was literally like the most
exciting thing that's ever happened
he's like my guy not my i don't want to
[ __ ] him not my hall pass but
he's the person that when i see him like
i'm approaching you i'm talking to you
i'm freaking out
i ran up to him at i had just done um
rogan's podcast for the first time
so i was so like i
just and i just talked about how much i
love survivor
and specifically jeff probst and then
i'm at
a coffee shop i see jeff probst and i i
go oh my god
he's wearing a fedora i'm like oh my god
jeff i like run up i'm like it's jeff
and his summer fedora i knew it
and i was like he's wearing a fedora or
you are a summer fedora
no but i was thinking we should have a
fedora episode ooh
should we try to bring them back we
should try to bring them back well no i
i had a fedora stage as well i'm trying
to burn pictures of them
but it was so good for the bald men you
know my ex
yeah for the bald men to have a new like
thing
anyway so i um
run up to jeff props i'm like oh my god
oh my god and i have to legitimize
legitimize myself immediately like my
ego is like he can't just think i'm a
regular fan and i go oh my god i was
just on joe rogan's podcast and i just i
brought you up
i said you're you're the best wow good
good
opening because i was like i just need
him to know i know powerful people i was
like
he must know nobody knows my gift is
name dropping joe rogan my dear friend
rogie
texted him today uh hasn't texted me
back but he will
he's busy but um so then i like freak
out and he was like you should come on
the show
and i was like wait he invited you he
said the
line you should come on the show now
does that mean you should apply for the
show
yeah does that mean [ __ ] i got you in
and i went no no i can't i'm like every
time i like pull an all-nighter i disown
my entire family
i can't tell you how many times i've had
to just take a nap and then call my
parents and be like
i'm so sorry lord lord forgive me
please um anyway so
um yeah he was like you should come on
the show i got a picture with him i
looked so ugly and i never posted it it
was so bad
wait i need you to i need to see it i'll
find it we can post it on here but it
was i was like
it's very unani like to not post a
picture
of jeff jeff it wasn't the right time
either like there's like gonna be a
moment where i need to post this and it
might what better time than you
just talking about a man manifesting
that into existing actually meeting him
and then in him inviting you
on the actual show that you're obsessed
and let's be wrong i think i should do
the [ __ ] show i think that is my
bucket list
klyla lucy nicotine is a company founded
by caltech scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative
finally tobacco alternatives that don't
suck i love lucy
i had the show i love
lucy the nicotine company because
um i obviously bobby smokes bobby's been
a smoker for so many years
but this has really cut down the amount
of smoking
and it's really helped him achieve his
long-term goal of ultimately quitting
smoking because it replaces the nicotine
in him and it's it's enough
to give him that same amount of buzz as
a cigarette
well the good thing about this is that
it's been researched and developed for
three years to be made for people
not patients and lucy has created a
nicotine gum with four milligrams of
nicotine that comes in three flavors
wintergreen cinnamon and pomegranate
they also have a lozenge
with four milligrams of nicotine that
comes in cherry ice citrus and mint
lucy lozenges and gums are fsa and hsa
eligible so you can use fsa cards to
purchase lucy now and it's convenient
and discreet products can be enjoyed
anywhere on flights at work on the go
or even in the gym also i'm sending it
to my grandma
she's 81 years old and she needs this if
you're a smoker and you let's say
are on a six hour flight how how amazing
it is that you can you don't have to
worry about
withdrawing on the plane well you know
what literally if i had had
this when i visited my grandma i could
just hand this to her in her car
ride so she wouldn't have to stop the
car and smoke you know it just i think
that if you're a non-smoker but you have
it for smokers in your life
it will do you a favor it's 20 21 guys
get rid of your cigarettes unplug your
vape
definitely unplug your vape throw out
the dip and get some lucy nicotine gum
or lozenges this is the real deal and a
subscription to lucy comes directly to
your door each month it's so simple and
you don't have to leave your house
because lucy has delivery
down lucy lozenges and gums are also fsa
and hsa eligible so you can spend your
pre-tax dollars on them
you guys trash tuesday listeners can go
to lucy.co
and use promo code tuesday to get 20
off all of the products on your first
order including the gum or the lozenges
that's lucy.co and use promo code
tuesday at checkout
also i have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco and nicotine is an
addictive chemical
but go to lucy.co and be sure to use
that promo code
tuesday
so hey let me tell you a story i know
somebody who
obviously did survivor and she did
really well and i'm gonna go ahead and
say that i have traveled with this
person
and she is very unathletic
very sort of picky with difficult
so i was like if that person went far in
survivor
i think anyone can now you actually have
a lot more in your arsenal than this
person and i so i think that you could
legitimately kill it
i do like when i think about exercising
it does cross my mind that i'm like i
if i were on the challenge or if i was
on survivor like
i would have to get ready for it they
don't give you enough time
you just get cast i think that's the
best part you got to bring all your body
fat with you
and also there's so many uh seasons
where people like don't get that
sometimes
you're wearing the clothes that you come
in so there's so many episodes where
there's just girls in like long skirts
that
didn't realize that they were gonna do
you know how how valuable
i i have trouble with that word valuable
a long skirt would be in terms of just
overall
like protection from the elements you
could use it as like a dress
you could pull it up so many things you
could use it as a fishing net
but you know my issue with chafing i
need
any cloth between so you'll never be
caught red-handed with a long skirt
i'll be caught i'll be caught red side
bleeding gushing blood
just gushing blood um yeah no but i
yeah i know i would i would i'm scared
of it and i just
know my my personality is what would
lose it for me
but i think that again i'm annoying we
have a friend
um again she got brought
i got a re-watch that season because i'm
pretty sure she got brought
to the end because people knew they
weren't gonna vote for her
well i think that she was that season's
like villain but she allied herself
correctly because she's a very bright
woman
there is something about this person
that i will say is she is one of the
craftiest people
i've ever met also she's so funny she's
so funny and i imagine her
just being so like charming and really
like winning people over in the
beginning in that way
yeah um so yeah
i i like a funny villain yes no it's
i talked to corrine who is the villain
of um
gabon i think there was a couple she was
a villain of and it's so funny she's
such a [ __ ] villain
it's so hilarious and if you think about
it if you remember you're on a game
and you're there to entertain on
television that's what's so good about
it it's like
go crazy be insane i just think that i
would be too concerned with how i was
looking because i have another career
[Laughter]
i think you just go balls to the wall
dude one there was a guy on there that
got me tooed on it he's a hollywood
um it's he's people's manager that's so
embarrassing if you're
he was like touching all the girls and
giving them a massage on the island
yes and then they like weren't kicking
him off and then finally like these
girls went to this one woman
this older woman who's uh she was like a
manager at a trucking place or something
she's like this tough [ __ ]
and she went and she like called him out
and then everyone for some reason
defended the guy and then she got voted
out and she was like
i was just defending the girls it was
just such an a good example of the media
movement where it's like
oh no if you come out you might get
[ __ ] yeah because
but i will say but eventually he did get
in trouble i'm just really surprised
that someone
could feel sexual when your basic needs
of food clothing and shelter are not met
because that [ __ ] and that those balls
are stinking
i'm sorry it's just not for me when i am
hungry
forget your dick yeah forget it tuck it
away put it away
put it in a [ __ ] shelter and like
lock it away for
days now okay wait so jeff rope said to
me when i said i'm just i'm a nightmare
when i don't see burgers everyone is and
i'm like
ah i think maybe like
if i'm sleep deprived hungry to the
point where i have a headache
um yeah those are usually my
but how are you like are you able to
pull it together when you're like
yeah yeah i i think that i'm really good
on low blood sugar
i've tested myself before because i used
to be obviously like
eating disordery so i would do like
extreme things with my body like extreme
um
physical stuff and then extreme
starvation um
so i don't know now at 36 it might be
different but can you
pull up do we have it or not finally
jordan
i go through my phone this is so sad can
you pull up
um you guys we're a huge production here
okay this is we're in a
huge town studio this is this should not
be happening we're in hollywood studio
it's um it's maslow's hierarchy of needs
it's maslow's hierarchy of needs
basically oh wait
i thought that's what you were saying
your wi-fi password or your wi-fi
name was i was like jesus christ i was
like it fits you and it makes sense but
you'd actually like my wife by password
i should give it away because no one
[ __ ] can i give it away george
oh george says ixnay
yeah and as i said no but my wi-fi
password is so good
oh it's so cute mine is like you know
fi two nine six three four five i just
never changed it
that's yeah that's that's the best way
to do it like it's
not happening i don't want people to
know [ __ ] about me well i don't think
you're able to guess because sometimes
you can guess
because i always live in apartments and
i'm always like oh that [ __ ] is
probably like
sandy with a side of salt or whatever
you know and that person's like i can
tell
um well when i was younger i was
obsessed with the movie
remember i my prom dress was based on
halle berry yes but also i was obsessed
with remember when she showed her boobs
and swordfish
yes and i went to the movies for that
and it was like oh my god
women we have arrived like that was my
teenage day is that why you wear fish
earrings
but that was like when i was younger
when i was like on friendster
and all of that i all my passwords are
swordfish because
the [ __ ] movie was about so dumb that
i was obsessed with
her i had one that was like mary kate
and ashley olsen fan 69 i always had 69.
what's the weirdest email address you've
had was the first one you ever made for
yourself
oh i have one that's anne frankfan69 at
yahoo.com
that's still active if you want to throw
me one i i never look at it but
my first oh god this is so horrible
but you just like you're so green when
you first get the internet and you want
to like reel in boys
was so mine was pop that [ __ ] 84 out oh
my god
at hotmail.com
my second one was tickleme702 is this
after your dad passed
he was passing see you were going
through [ __ ] that's
a girl going through shit's handle i
threw my ass on meds real quick
they're like oh she ain't right they're
like we're gonna pill that [ __ ] too
here we go annie maslow's hierarchy of
needs
physiological needs food water warm
threats without that i'm sorry the
intimate sex
all the way up top and the green there i
am incapable of
yeah it's you don't get my warm [ __ ]
blanket during this time of chill
no your dick's not warming my vagina up
my vagina's warming your dick up
there's just no way that that that [ __ ]
is even
like blinking it's not moving
thank you george for 30 years later
finally pulling up
it also looks like the worst one you
carry
and they're going to be horrified
george has made a million dollars off of
us wait don't tell them we make a
million dollars because then uh you know
the people will try to explore well i'm
kidding but also we could make a million
dollars if one of you would just buy a
picture of my feet
finally okay it's a million dollars in
quarters and you have to pay shipping
here's what i
i proposed a little something about that
by the way for only fans
i think that we should all be tap
dancing on some cake
is that is that still for some reason i
thought you were gonna say k
and i was like that sounds so fun tap
dancing on kay
wait do those two activities match yes
sure
sure i've never done ketamines i don't
know what well people do ketamine at
like
at raves and stuff a lot so i would
assume but a lot of times yeah i just
really
oh ketamine i miss you i won't do you
anymore unless you're prescribed by a
real doctor
i'm like me like kala kala can you
reinstate your nurses things so i can do
okay
i'd have to go back to school to be a
nurse practitioner for that that's what
i got you
you would have been a good like that
would have been your good rap name
special okay
i think he's a nurse practitioner i was
like no you would not have been good
at that you'd been so bad at that
uh would you like a question yes let's
take a question oh i was like looking
like that was going to be the question
i'm still trying to read things and love
needs i also think it's funny that you
brought up the pyramid you read one
thing well no i'm just saying if red is
not met
neither of those safety needs belonging
love needs esteem needs
self-actualization
can be met it's like if i don't have my
basics i'm not
looking for dick right so that's just
how
i am i don't know if maybe that dude on
survivor is on a
reverse that flip the pyramid some men
are just the like the cheaters and the
liar the ones that just like want to
[ __ ] so bad like they're just so
it's like their dick is like pulling
them into the room like i always imagine
them like trying to stop themselves
in a doorway is their dicks like
thrusting them through a door well
i do know a guy who has to jerk off in
his office bathroom
um every lunch break like he
george that's very inappropriate the
door's locked
with us in it now george wait have you
ever
one time i was hooking up with this guy
i used to hook up with a bartender
and we were like in the bathroom at the
bar he worked at and i was like
i was blowing him and he and then i got
i was too drunk i like started like
i was trying to get my sea legs like i
was like oh i'm too dizzy i'm about to
throw up you know
so i like needed him i was like i'm just
gonna take like a break
and then he just started jerking out but
he stood in front of the door and i was
like um and then he like i went to like
when he was like no and then he just
kept going
and i stand i was like at one point i
was like flossing
i'm like okay like are we done yet and
they just in the ground and i was like
can i have some jager and he's like of
course that's like the laziest thing
just like flip it open for them to see
go trick off in the corner i'm just
gonna prop it up so you can see from
afar
i'm just like can i go why am i here
okay george what do we have
hi my name is miriam i wanted to ask you
guys
uh what's your favorite memory
okay bye oh my gosh
hi miriam
annie and i are really bad at this time
because it's like unless you're super
super specific like broad questions like
we short circuit
and we also have so many memory like
we're just spitting memories because if
it was esther i'm gonna go ahead and say
it's movies with popcorn
or like working at johnny rock high
school
high school driving by her boyfriend's
house yes i think i do have an
overall favorite time in my life and
um was that when you were popping that
puss
[Laughter]
i was in computer class learning um
my most favorite recent memory is what i
can give you and that is
being in the philippines with my entire
family in 2019 with george included
that just those two weeks of just
being in my homeland with everyone i
love feeling good
loving myself loving bobby yeah that's a
good feeling i think
yeah i yeah it's got to be like hanging
out with my
nieces and nephews for sure when i
surprised my nieces and then my niece
went
are you a hologram are you really here
and i'm like
it's me that must feel so good it's i
just love them whenever i do
i so i do this meditation or this um
visualization that i talked about when
i'm getting coins thrown at me
but um like there's a whole process of
like getting down into the
that feeling of walking into this room
and creating this thing
and i can skip that if i just imagine my
niece is hugging me
i just like imagine them hugging me and
i'm already like have that
warmth i just love them but my dad and i
i think when we
my favorite time maybe when we were at
the um post office once
and i was like kind of joke antagonizing
my dad just we were i was
writing a letter to my friend and and he
was just like hurry up annie and i was
like i'll be done when i'm done you know
we were just like joke [ __ ] with each
other
and then this old lady was next to me
and then she went to leave and before
she left she like was holding the door
and she like stopped and pivoted and she
went you know what young lady you're a
real itch
and i started laughing so hard and my
dad like saw me laughing but he hadn't
heard what she said
so we were walking outside it was
raining and my dad's like what did she
say i'm like she said that i was an
itch and he goes oh [ __ ] i wish i had
heard her i would have said she's more
of an aunt
and we were just laughing we were like
on the ground in the rain crying
laughing
and then immediately like we're laughing
sorry we called my mom and tell the
story and she's like i don't get it
like you [ __ ]
i think that is my number one um my one
of my other favorite pre-pandemic
um stories was going to a bleachers
concert
at the fonda theater with my sister and
i love shows
that are small like coachella is fun
these big
shows are fun [ __ ] but small shows are
the best right
but it wasn't the show was amazing love
the bleachers they were just myself my
sister now you know when you're just
feeling that song
wait bleachers are the ones that sang
what's their song
don't take the money um i want to i want
to get better
um a lot i agree with one of those i
want to get better but i'm taking the
money
um and so um so
you know when you're just feeling in
that moment when you're in the song and
you're like [ __ ] finally your favorite
song
is being played at the end of the show
the lead singer jack antonoff
he in the moment in this like passion he
he throws his water bottle into the
audience because he
thinks it's um oh it the cap is open can
i guess
yeah did you um do a bridge
and then open your vagina and then it
flew right into it
and you caught it i i wish close
so close but what ended up happening is
the water didn't actually empty out
completely and it wasn't his fault
because i think he does this and i like
every show
but it basically boomeranged into the
person next to me and hit her square in
the [ __ ] nose in the middle my sister
and i just really just
[ __ ] and all we heard was pop and then
her we could see her head
do this and then she turns to us and
she's crying and she's just
her whole thing is bleeding she goes
and my sister and i like rush her to the
bathroom but she's being such a [ __ ] to
us
get off of me get off me i was like my
sister's a nurse my sister's trying to
tell her to like what to do let's put
pressure on the wound
but that's one of my favorite memories
not because she got hurt
but because it was such god's way of
saying
i'm glad you're enjoying this moment
yeah but
you know not so fast yeah but also
you do kind of get to continue to enjoy
it no and then when she was being a [ __ ]
in the bathroom
my sister and i looked at each other we
were like let's the sun's not over
we still have a minute 20 left and we
just had the best minute 20 of our lives
we were
laughing eventually you know but that's
that's one of those things where you're
like unfortunate but also hilarious yeah
i did we did mushrooms we didn't realize
to get we were gonna get that [ __ ] up
once
and when i lived in santa fe we someone
gave me just like a pill bottle filled
with like crushed mushrooms so i put it
on like a pizza with me and my friends
at this bar
we were eating it and uh and then my
friend came with her mom and we just
all of a sudden were tripping so hard
when she got there with her mom
and my friend i remember looking at her
mom was like older and like kind of
wrinkly and her
she goes why is your face made of ropes
and i'm like oh my god and i like look
over at my friend and he's like
he's just sitting there crazy and i was
trying to tell some story i'm always
like trying to be the one that like
deals with the cops or the parents at a
party i'm always like i'm fine i got
this
and i was telling this story and then
about cnn or something and i go
yeah i saw it on cnn and the minute i
did the extra ends i was like
take your mom out of your d like get out
of here and then we drove my friends
chrysler lebaron um convertible like
into the desert to my friend's house and
like the stars
i just remember like this is the best
night of my life and then a pink floyd
block came on the radio and it was like
classique that is a classic call the
moon hither it came to me
we said we didn't have memories but i
feel like we overdid the homework it was
too many memories we'll be editing one
or two out
and probably the ones i've repeated
already
speaking of memory uh it's fading
but it's been a pleasure thank you for
putting up with all of
our um technical difficulties we should
have named the show technical
difficulties with george kim all
technical difficulties oh
boy we [ __ ] up um but um
we've been trash tuesday thank you for
being our lovable slugs
and we will see you next week hop into
the dumpster babies
[Music]
you